say something very [ __ ] can i just
say something about this guy george
why would he you know he has notebooks
right he has like notes he has all these
things
he's a producer right don't say anything
until i finish okay
do you promise back up george back up so
we see
he sets up this like production meeting
to pitch to a production company
right i don't know anything about it i
wake up and claudia goes wake up you
have to go to this
pitch meeting at a company i go what
i don't want to go you told george you
would go and it's with like the
high up guy right he's the president of
one of the right yeah
so i go oh do i drive there
she goes no he's gonna pick you up he
meets me up front
and we drive to the [ __ ] place okay
and i go what are we pitching he's like
i got some pitches
oh my god one of them was the first one
was mediocre at best okay the second and
third one
were not even this is what it was they
were there don't don't do that to him no
no
don't do that to him sweetie do what
don't like him the first one was great
the first one was great i pitched the
first one i know it's good because he's
saying i pitched the first one was that
the first one the game show
no no it was something else the first
one i'm like that has some legs it's not
there yet yeah but it's something
but the second and third one oh my god
well there's a stage and you're there
and there's people there
and you guys do crazy things you know
and i go what because yeah i mean it's
like every week is different
but it's crazy with your friends that's
what it sounds like to me right
i go george you can't pitch that we'll
get kicked out of the [ __ ] room
okay how about this one you and your
friends you guys go wild
are we just chasing out the adjectives
i'm not kidding you that i don't know
specifically what they were rambunctious
they were
generally like that and then all of a
sudden i'm in the car
sweating okay we gotta what are we gonna
do
we're [ __ ] so then i go i go to george
i go
just follow my lead right you don't
pitch any pitch the first one
all right but you just sit there so we
go into this the nice
office right there's like a long table
the guy comes out
and with his assistant we know the
assistant what's his name
russell wrestling i love foreign
and um we got out of there you know
okay i thought this is where it gets a
little bit [ __ ] up though
yeah and then because i pitched on
something no can i can i just hold on
bobby comes home
yeah bobby comes home i haven't even
gotten my rebuttal yet keep going you're
stressing me out with your face already
i was home and i was like oh did you
guys pitch the game show
they're like no he's like no but we
pitched something else it's like well
what did you pitch
you know the thing about me being
handcuffed to so-and-so i was like
you mean my idea
you guys pitched my idea and i wasn't
even in the room okay i just say
something
ether you [ __ ] you sabotaged me baby
because you brought me in a room with
this [ __ ] jackass right no you're not
gonna get a robot
start your own podcast pal start your
own [ __ ] podcast pal all right
let me something somewhere okay you put
me in a [ __ ] corporate room with this
[ __ ] jackass
right right and i and then i have to
[ __ ] defend for myself
i'm stealing ideas i'm surviving it's
going to be mine
we came up to go together maybe we did
let's be honest let's be
let's be honest also shouldn't i have
been in that room if you were pitching
our idea yeah let me say this let's be
another honest they like that idea and
they might do it and then you'll become
a producer yeah
all right so there's that but do you
have anything to
i don't want you to say anything yeah
do you want okay you want to say
something i want to hear a little bit
yeah go ahead
okay number one uh we were supposed to
meet on thursday night
so we could go over these ideas true
because the man who's going to pitch him
the man who's going to sell him is you
the king i'm just a lowly connector
you know i can corroborate this so
that's what
i want to write down connector because i
i don't i don't forget that because
that's ridiculous
connecting you bobby yeah yeah number
two the idea that you made fun of so
much
the idea you made fun of so much you're
like oh it's like a korean game show but
like what did they do it's just like
different things like crazy things huh
i love that you went in the room and you
were like
oh yeah and then like you just like
started riffing on other ideas you were
like
oh yeah and then i had this idea i was
trying to do with uh joe coy
joe coy but it was just a japanese game
show yeah but
it was it was exactly the same thing as
my japanese instead of korean
except japanese and everybody was like
okay oh yeah that's a great idea you and
joe call you to japanese game show okay
okay
okay stop will you stop stop turning up
i would like to say one thing though
yeah
i will say that george's idea of the
game show
gilbert and i have you know so angry
right now and it is really good
okay stop okay you maybe just didn't
understand it though no i i i
i okay let me say this to you friend my
girlfriend
all right i understand every single
thing that's going on right now
okay i'm a [ __ ] conduit for [ __ ]
knowledge
let me say something right now dude
you're not a connector
okay you know what you are an appendage
that's good a dead one a dead one okay
well
one that doesn't work there's one of
them you didn't let me finish you need
to always be with you
okay can i say something oh so second
then the reason why i threw the joe coy
i was stuck right and in my head i'm
like joe still wants to do this
game show idea and i knew that i didn't
have the pitch down
but i threw his name in there to create
some sort of excitement
juices right some juices so that's the
only reason why i did that
okay and thirdly right um
the idea that they like is the one that
klein and i came up with
okay let me say something also thanks
for coming with me
i really do enjoyed the car rides we had
and then afterwards we had katsudon
it was a good lunch and i enjoyed myself
okay sorry for attacking you
okay i'm sorry for attacking you sir all
right because i saw it on your face you
were hurt a little bit
and um you know i don't think that he's
hurt george has the thickest skin
out of anyone i've ever known he gets
abused by him
you know another thing i will
corroborate the fact that
for three days leading up to that
meeting he
texted me multiple times and i could not
get through to you
and remember and you were like give me
ideas give me ideas so we can like put
it together
and he was just not in the correct
headspace to give anything back to me
therefore i couldn't give anything to
you
all good all good so yeah my hands were
tied but i'm glad that you pitched my
idea behind my back and that's gonna be
a hit now let me say something
you will not be a producer